I don't think it's possible
I think it's extraordinarily difficult
to do to change the Constitution I don't
think that would be accomplished I think
doing away with the second amendment
would clearly increase violence to the
extent that you disarm law-abiding
citizens you make it easier for
criminals to go and commit crime getting
rid of the Second Amendment all of these
protesters all of the people taking to
the streets said that was not the main
purpose but yet it has come up because
former Supreme Court justice the former
Supreme Court justice Stevens John Paul
Stevens writing in an op-ed in The New
York Times in 2008 the Supreme Court
overturned Chief Justice burgers and
others long settled understanding of the
second amendments limited reached by
rule the ruling in District Columbia vs.
Heller that there was an individual
right to bear arms that decision which I
remain convinced was wrong and certainly
was debatable has provided the NRA with
a propaganda weapon of immense power
overturning that decision via
constitutional amendment to get rid of
the Second Amendment would be simple and
would do more to weaken the NRA s
ability to stymie legislative debate and
to block constructive gun control
legislation than any other available
option well what about all of that let's
bring in our panel former CIA analyst
and nationally syndicated radio host
buck Sexton Catherine Lucy White House
reporter for The Associated Press and
Kimberly Strasse a member of the
editorial board at The Wall Street
Journal Kimberly when I saw this I said
wait is this real and sure enough that
op-ed did did show up in the New York
Times yeah it's crazy I think justice
Stevens got a little too used to only
having to get five votes on the Supreme
Court
obviously repealing an amendment and
repealing one that is as beloved in many
states of this union as this one would
require super majorities of the states
to sign on it's an impossible task and
for that matter even getting some of
these proposals that have been put
forward by these groups that want gun
control they're nowhere
here it as Diane Feinstein is intimated
in the Senate the last time they tried
to do this they would have been lucky to
have got 40 votes so in that way not
much has changed politically in
Washington so Katherine does this hurt
somehow the effort that we just saw over
the past few days that that now this
this left liberal justice who by the way
was appointed and nominated by a
Republican is suggesting get rid of the
second amendment well I think what we
need to note is that none of the we
haven't heard from the organizers of the
March or the some of the leaders on this
issue really backing this idea I looked
a little bit on Twitter to see who was
who was getting on board and one of the
students who is a key member of the the
March organizers he tweeted today that
this wasn't something that he was was
looking for so it's clear that there are
people trying to put some distance
between themselves and this statement
but that said it does play into this
argument you'll hear from you you know
gun owners and the National Rifle
Association this anxiety that you know
the real agenda from from some of these
gun control advocates is to really try
and repeal the Second Amendment yeah
buck well I have to say that there's a
continued anxiety about it because we
keep seeing instances like this with
very prominent voices from the left or
from the Democrat Party who say what we
all think they actually believe which is
that they would like there to be if not
an outright ban something very close to
a ban on firearms and private hands of
all kind quite honestly it's also the
only intellectually consistent argument
we often hear about incremental changes
people will talk about common-sense gun
reforms and then there won't be a
consensus on what those reforms would be
Brett well if they're so obvious and so
common-sense one would think that they
could all get on the same sheet of music
I walk through one of these protest
marches in New York over the weekend and
there were signs about banning ar-15s
there was a sign that I saw that said
Trump kills kids so the rhetoric is
clearly way out of line and overheated
and I would just also note that in that
New York Times editorial from a former
Supreme Court justice they misidentified
the
sure of a weapon at the very top of the
editorial as a rifle when it was in fact
a musket which for those of us who watch
this tube a closely is not surprising
from the New York Times now here's some
of the the sound of the president and
bringing up the Second Amendment as
we've heard over you know recent weeks
now takeaway Houston we are not trying
to take everybody's guns away and the
NRA wants people to think that their
fear mongers there's nobody that loves
the Second Amendment more than I do I
think all of these young people these
leaders I'm making very clear as it's a
false choice to suggest you you're
either in favor of the Second Amendment
or you want to take everyone's guns away
so Kimberly is there a way to get this
debate to a place where something
actually happens in Congress in the
short term no and I think that that's
the important thing for everyone to
understand in Congress despite everyone
talking about how these marchers signal
some new front and some new change in
the politics the reality is in
Washington this is probably the most Pro
Second Amendment Republican Congress
potentially in history nobody's going
down the road of assault weapons bans
they just passed the fix Nick's bill as
part of the omnibus which does shore up
some things in our background system
many of them feel confident that that
does provide them a way of saying that
they're doing something about this issue
but they're not going to take up any
legislation on this the question is
whether or not this plays someway in the
midterms in the fall whether or not it
potentially hurts Senate Democrats who
up for re-election and Trump States or
whether it potentially hurts Republicans
who are in suburban districts where
there may be a lot of Women Voters or
others who are watching this and they're
not as committed to second amendment
issues we just won't know that until
November comes along how many times
Katherine do you think we'll hear do you
agree with Justice John Paul Stevens
I'm sure that's going to be a talking
point going forward absolutely but yes I
think to Kimberly's point in the short
term we're not likely to see
any sweeping change the Omnibus had some
incremental changes and there's not
there's really no momentum right now for
any kind of big major gun bill